[Musique]
enceinte de 32 semaines
elle arrive à l'urgence pour une
réaction allergique grave
et ça c'est malin valérie le père de
on a encore un coup derrière le miroir
le scénario change en fonction des soins
que reçoit le patient simulateur il
s'agit d'un des quatre exercices de
simulation portant sur les chocs
anaphylactiques qui vont mettre une
vingtaine de médecins a les preuves
qu'on a un corps par exemple parce que
le passage après une piqûre de guêpe
devient de plus en plus un choc donc la
pression diminue de plus en plus ça nous
arrivait à l'occasion ou est-ce qu'une
au traitement standard ne fonctionne pas
pu faut être bien préparé on sait que
dans la pratique ou dans le monde en
général il ya parfois certaines lacunes
où il ya des choses où on doit se mettre
à jour régulièrement
heureusement l'anaphylaxie on n'en voit
pas tous les jours mais quand ça arrive
il faut qu'on s'assoit près des
anesthésistes et des médecins d'urgence
d'un peu partout au québec viennent sur
les bancs d'école pour s'entraîner à
l'académie chum le temps d'une
demi-journée
nous notre équipe s'occupe à l'académie
d'opérer à partir de la régie tous les
signes vitaux
on s'occupe de maquiller les espaces
parce que le plus près possible la
réalité nos espaces ici au centre
d'apprentissage reflète exactement les
espaces clinique de l'hôpital
donc on est en mesure de faire de a à z
la seule différence c'est que c'est pas
dépasser assez des robots c'est même
simulation ont déjà permis aux équipes
de la clinique d'allergie du chum
d'améliorer leurs performances dans les
situations d'urgence dans les mois qui
ont suivi et onu 3 en effet l'excellent
étage parce qu'on fait des processus qui
peuvent amener ça et le niveau de
réponse de toute l'équipe était
extrêmement bon les soins temps ce sont
arrivés en trois minutes sur les lieux
ces patients robots dans les hôpitaux
font en sorte que les véritables
patients reçoivent de meilleurs soins
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal